teaser alors c'est très simple ryan dunn
en doudoune on a une chemise en dessous
et un débardeur à chaque fois on va
lancer le dé celui qui fera le plus
petit nombre devra enlever quelque chose
d'acquis l'accord ryan oui voilà il ya
eu ce match tu veux la vraie la vraie
histoire sûrement et attention pas bon
je vais vous dire la vraie histoire je
jure que c'est vrai pour ceux qui ont
regardé le prime
on a reçu un livre ouais d'accord où il
y avait toutes nos prestataires fauteuil
dans toutes nos prestations du début à
la fin du prime et à la fin le dixième
chapitre donc le brouillard d'elle comme
le dixième chapitre il y avait une page
blanche et on s'est dit qu'on allait
faire une photo on le savait à l'avancé
que la dernière photo ce sera ça pour
finir bien le l'histoire tout ça va ça
pour ça ces domaines mais ça devait pas
prendre autant d'ampleur
la séquence a fait pression sur la tête
d'un chat sur l'appel sur la tête de
shy'm même sur la tête de chaque syllabe
à pécho sans rigoler je sais pas ce que
je fais je le fais les cheveux verts je
vais l'annoncer à ce qu'on appelle la
hongroise
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
arrêtez tout il a doublé la mise bas à
moi ben ammar se connaît et moi la
mauricie ferro allait mal à la main ont
fait salle
mais là elle al alam en date de
l'échéance lemonade d'officiers nommé il
ya deux choses qui veut savoir la ddt
l'a fait sur le sur le plateau c'est
aussi un travail d'acteur il ya des noms
mis à l'essai était ému bien sûr de
phényle à ryan êtes fidèles de tous fils
d'alice et ben oui il est fidèle à une
période de sa vie maintenant je sais
qu'ils les droits comme la justice
serait certainement et j'ai été infidèle
à une fois c'est vrai voilà ouais ouais
c'est vrai nom mais je mérite vous êtes
fériés je me suis vite totalement fait
griller et en plus elles se sont devenus
potes les deux et elles m'ont fait un
coup genre magnifique
elles sont venues elles m'ont dit bon
bah voilà surprise l'autre venait de
marseille
enfin j'avais les deux en face de moi et
je me sentis très con way
voilà j'ai rigolé nerveusement ça a dû
coûter plus cher au restaurant il ya ça
aussi
voilà et j'adresse mes copains quand
même les trois copains ou à dos à dos
elle entraîne entre elles je sais pas je
sais pas peut-être peut-être je sais pas
du tout si on à mireille dumas
[Applaudissements]
brad est mon chiffre
j'ai toujours eu 4 à l'école vieux
quaterback ça m'a tout de suite j'ai été
sur france 4
non mais tu vois toi apparemment c'est
aussi procès le
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien
babar ahmad ahmad abed ahmad et alibaba
papa papa baba rivasi aironi le livre en
somme comme ça où tu as vu il ya une
page blanche tu m'as déjà vu lire un
livre comme ça avec une heure qu'est ce
que oui ou non elle te plaisait mais non
sauver ce qu'il ya de bien c'est que lui
quand il arrive en débardeur sur la tête
de ma mère on voit le gars et les gosses
boy tout moi quand j'arrive on me dit
pour la plomberie sans eau il a bloqué
l'arrivée d'un carreleur ya le père leur
s'arrêter là qu'est ce qui se passe
capillairement on est sur quoi laquelle
pro-gt by larm ans on n'y a pas de
projet c'est n'importe quoi ce illégal
j'aime beaucoup moi c'est beaucoup
ah ouais ouais ouais ça derrière ou non
mais non non franchement j'aime bien
c'est vrai que qu'est ce tu vas faire tu
t'es sur un carré plongeant tuba coupé
va essayer et réessayer je dois laisser
pousser pour un rôle et voilà ce qui se
passe c'est quoi là on va reprendre la
planète des singes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors servir dans ces tranches est là la
zone à s'écarter à temps
la balle a alors annoncé comme ça ah oui
j'ai eu peur d'elle c'est un moment de
grande tension et je peux faire aussi
attention regardez soit peut-être de
manière sûre
[Applaudissements]
avec le corps que t'as pas besoin de
cheveux teints non mais sans déconner
pourquoi tu as les cheveux il a le corps
et un autre guy la lose you done
je le connais on a pris notre douche
ensemble après le tennis très alors eh
ben et alors j'ai pris j'ai failli vous
tromper que le tai chi 12
ah oui
no 7 la forme d'une bouteille de tahiti
douche
oui oui parce qu'ils habitent marne et
hui
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
rien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et ça